this is basic training living better
through libertarian lifestyle choices
and instruction today we're talking with
Balon linic and he is the executive
director of keep food legal food is
delicious food is important what does
keep food legal do we try to keep it
legal we are devoted to the premise that
people should be allowed to grow ray is
produced by sell cook eat and drink the
foods of their own choosing we should be
the ones making the choices right you
and me well every time you turn around
there's something new on the list that
the government has banned in California
it's trans fat it's shark fin soup four
loko came under a lot of fire when
essentially it's the same thing as Jack
and Coke now what do we have today well
we have some tasty tacos here prepared
with four loko and what do you think the
four loko gives the tacos it removes all
the disgustingness from the four loko
and it infuses into the the tacos and
makes them taste fantastic no why does
Warlow go get such a bad rap it's truly
vile to drink it tastes terrible but I'm
not the arbiter of taste and neither
should be the government what is what is
the ultimate message here at I guess
like that I think freedom of choice is
important when it comes to food we're
trying to defend the right of people to
make their own decisions and whether
that's a farmer or whether that's a
restaurant or whether that's a chef it's
important that people have the freedom
to make their own food please consume 1
i'll dig it
Baylen minikin keep food legal keeping
us free and safe one taco to time cheers
to you my friends fresh hot Amish urine
hmm